j'accueille là
[Musique]
chanter
à
rien
alors
chose qui
je ne chantais
le
à
[Musique]
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
l'âme à la maison de la ratp à paris
pour un casting un peu spécial alors là
je vais rejoindre
membre de jury et les artistes pour
commencer le concours le grand casting
du printemps du métro de la ratp
et oui la ratp là me connaît bien
puisqu'elle a fait ses débuts en
chantant dans le métro parisien il est
temps que vous alors j'ai commencé à
jouer dans le métro en 1990
puis direction la loge où elle retrouve
les autres membres du jury parmi
lesquels manu dibango et inna modja
[Musique]
on n'est pas encore au suicide ça va ça
va
et en tant que juré l'âme n'est pas très
à l'aise c'est un honneur ma montée
samedi mal de juger des gens fait donc
son retour
je sais que ce sont tous des artistes de
talent et
mettre des notes de médecins mais bon on
est là pour le fun voilà pour cette date
et on est là pour s'amuser mais petit à
petit elle se laisse entraîner par les
candidats qui défilent
et prend même son rôle à coeur en ôtant
tout
et elle a un vrai coup de foudre pour
l'un des candidats
et en show girl l'âme fini le casting
sur la scène
[Musique]
le lendemain on retrouve la chanteuse
dans le xviiie arrondissement de paris
en plein coeur de montmartre
je vais
je vais chercher des tissus
pour mes costumes de scène j'aime flâner
aussi
en plus ses mots donc c'est super et
puisque les dans le quartier l'âme en
profite pour passer voir un compositeur
c'est
bon c'est vrai quoi on est peu dire vous
avez repris une chanson de mon mari qui
l'avait composée quand on s'est
rencontrés d'accord à la base cette
chanson s'appelle la mia lamy
[Musique]
et
là
j'ai entendu la mélodie chantée par
terre ça m'a touché c'est très beau
une visite en coup de vent car c'est
déjà l'heure de retourner au travail
salut
jules abattoirs alors là nous allons
chez mon producteur de spectacles
on va rejoindre possible mon manager
frais du rêve et nous allons parler
business ce que j'aime le moins dans ce
métier c'est pas et business
et justement ils ont un nouveau projet à
lui présenté une maquette ces voix-là
fait simplement il la met plus belles
chansons d'amour ben moi je trouve que
c'est une très bonne idée j'aime
beaucoup la fiche là c'est la lame sobre
voilà c'est
ça fait du bien aussi ça qui l'a tout le
monde
dernier rendez vous de la journée avec
son manager lahm va rencontrer les
ex-membres de trust j'ai vraiment kiffé
c'est vraiment le monde rock américain
je vous dis à mon mari est américain il
a apprécié vous avez investi chacun deux
côtés est assez intéressant et ça va
permettre des blues il faut bien sûr
mais moi franchement ça sera un honneur
de chanter avec vous faire un duo
avec mon père et j'ai eu jean la noire
qui ne voient aussi ma voix en anglais
est complètement différente que quand je
chante en français c'est pas du tout
pareil si je fais petite-soeur gecol et
appelé l'état douleur je fais ma main
c'est un match au maroc et
je ne sais pas
non
une énergie débordante c'est des projets
plein la tête l'âme compte bien
retrouver son public très bientôt
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
l'âme la bienvenue sur le plateau de
tout le monde a parlé alors vous êtes né
le 1er septembre 1971 dans le 12e
arrondissement de paris sous le prénom
de la mia qui signifie la lumière en
arabe vous est la deuxième d'une fratrie
de sept enfants familles originaires de
tunisie alors quand vos parents se
rencontrent votre mère à 20 ans votre
père 40l et les danseuses orientales
elle rêve de devenir star quand elle est
arrivée en france elle pensait que sa
vie allait changer mais elle s'est
retrouvée très vite avec sept enfants
sur les bras à montreuil avec un mari
ouvrier grosse déception
alors là je la presse en date
au commissariat du coin là
oui oui tout à fait oui c'est exactement
ça oui c'était une période période très
difficile pour eux et
et ma mère avait plein de rêves
et en fin de compte
rien n'a marché ouais alors dit aussi
votre père appartenait à l'ancienne
génération c'était un peu honte alité du
bled quoi blédard il travaillait en
usine il rentrait le soir crevé il avait
un peu picolé souvent et quand il voyait
les gosses courir dans tous les sens ils
allaient plutôt lire le journal ou
dormir dans son coin quoi oui c'était
une façon pour lui de
de laisser ça derrière lui parce que ça
lui prenait la tête et
c'était une façon à lui de s'évader
ouais votre main était très déprimée
c'est ce qui la rendait sans doute
brutale et violente avec ses enfants ma
mère n'était pas fait pour être mère
ouais et s'est retrouvé à 27 ans elle
avait sept enfants ouais donc on se suit
et et puis elle a pété un câble à la
fait une grosse déprime et et
sa façon pour elle de s'exprimer de
c'était de nous tabasser une façon l2
je sais pas à doubler ses problèmes de
je ne sais pas je pourrai pas vous
expliquer pourquoi en tout cas été très
très dur fin bref la différence d'âge et
d'ambition entre vos parents la
promiscuité la pauvreté l'alcool et les
disputes qui s'en suivent seront à
l'origine de votre placement dans un
foyer de la dass vous avez six ans vous
y resterez jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans mais
vous dites j'ai pas vécu ça comme une
enfance misérable
d'abord on nous a placés dans un même
foyer avec mes frères et soeurs vous
avez grandi tous ensemble en fait on a
eu la chance d'avoir une juge qui était
un
cas très bien compris que la famille est
important et qu'on a besoin d'être
ensemble et elle a eu l'intelligence de
nous placer en même temps tous ensemble
dans le même foyer or je suis assez
content vous dit j'étais nourri logé
blanchi et assez heureuse finalement ah
oui tout à fait sains les misérables
c'était nous et
quand je suis arrivé dans les foyers où
on avait on connaissait enfin la fête
les repas en manger matin midi et soir
ce qui n'était pas le cas chez nous
manger une fois par jour où une fois
tous les deux jours où et là on n'était
pas là alors continue des violences que
votre mère avait exercé sur vous vous ne
souhaitez pas la revoir et en fait vous
la verrez à l'âge de 24 ans dans dix
huit ans plus tard oui en fait elle part
de la maison
suite à un adultère mon père la vire je
la vois partir de ma fenêtre et
c'était enfin c'est le malheureux à dire
ça sa mère mais c'était le plus beau
jour de ma vie je
j'ai vu cette femme partir qui me
n'étais pas heureux avec elle jeudi à
l'ats alors dès l'âge de 10 ans on vous
développez une vraie passion pour la
chanson et vous aimait plus que tout
interpréter les tubes de vos idoles
alors ça va de donna summer le françois
oui en fait on avait des éducateurs qui
qui aimait bien faire la fête et
et donc on faisait des boums et donc il
me donna summer dalida claude françois
puis moi je faisais du play back des
chorégraphies étaient
alors à l'époque à ceux qui ne croient
pas vous répondre et vous verrez un jour
je serai la première madonna arabe
parce qu'à l'école danse août un petit
peu de ma gueule parce qu'on aimerait un
temps tu te prends pour qui tu prends
pour madonna mais je leur disais quand
je pleurais je serai là
le problème c'est quand même époque vous
tomber dans la délinquance qu'elle
délinquance
déjà l'âge ou 12 ans fugue beaucoup de
filles ensuite
j'étais dans des bandes donc beaucoup de
vols conneries quoi de bien ouais à 15
ans vous est envoyé dans un nouveau
foyer et la l'éducatrice remarque votre
goût et votre talent pour la musique
c'est là que vous écrivez une lettre à
la dass pour leur expliquer que s'ils
veulent pas vous voir dans la rue dans
la drogue ou ou en prison bah il faut
qu'ils payent des cours de chant et
c'est ce qu'ils vont faire pendant deux
ans vous prendrez des cours aux ateliers
de la chanson de la ville de paris oui
ce qui n'était pas du tout évident à
l'époque parce que il avait un budget
pour des enfants mais la chanson pour
rester ça voulait rien dire mais
ils m'ont fait confiance
et j'ai passé deux ans aux amandiers au
théâtre des amandiers à ménilmontant
alors au départ j'étais un peu déçu
parce que moi j'aime bien la musique
black américaine et là je me vois
apprendre des chansons d'edith piaf
brassens sous sol qui était pas du tout
mon truc j'avais 16 ans donc c'était un
peu dur au départ mais grâce à cette
école j'ai découvert la chanson
française voilà a pas de là pendant dix
ans je vais chanter dans le métro dans
la rue avec votre mari qui vous
accompagne au saxophone et une copine
qui vous accompagnent la guitare voilà
mais ça me faisait un peu d'argent de
poche voilà vous envoyé des cassettes un
peu partout et j'imagine à l'époque
beaucoup de refus et je peux comprendre
parce que je sors mon que j'étais pas
j'étais pas prêtes à l'époque ouais et
puis c'est vrai qu'on s'est fait
beaucoup arrêté par les flics dans le
métro on n'avait pas l'autorisation de
chanter dans le métro alors c'est de
cette époque que date votre pseudo comme
on vous dit tout le temps que vous
chantez avec votre amie lamia devient
l'âme évidemment avec deux arts alors
pour vivre vous êtes obligé
effectivement de de fer serveuse de
faire des ménages mais vous dites la
seule chose que je n'ai jamais fait
s'est couché
jamais couché dans pour réussir dans ce
métier c'est très important
juste pour ça que je dis ça au jeune
fille qui se lancent dans ce métier
c'est pas parce qu'on couche qu'on va
réussir non donc vous n'êtes pas couché
un moment vous travaillé comme serveuse
dans le quartier de la bastille à paris
vous participez à une soirée hip hop ou
hot brass et c'est là que vous
rencontrez deux compositeurs sd au fbi
cool qui flashe sur vous et qui vous
font rencontrer hervé benhamou qui est
producteur et patron du label eben
musique en fait un premier single en
janvier 99 qui s'appelle j'ai le feeling
pas marché
oui et à l'époque malgré tout sept
choristes sur scène lui chanter avec
michael bolton avec mariah carey enfin
vous continuer malgré tout oui tout à
fait j'ai fait j'ai fait plein de trucs
à côté avant de faire ce single et après
ouais mais vous êtes tenace deux mois
plus tard vous sortez une reprise la
chanson de michel berger chanter pour
ceux qui sont loin de chez eux là c'est
un énorme succès le titre se classe
numéro 1 en radio numéro deux des ventes
et vous vantez 2 millions d'exemplaires
oui je compte sur sûre ni un reportage
sur les esclaves en arabie saoudite et à
cette chanson qui me revient à chaque
fois et j'en parle à mes producteurs et
je leur ai dit cette chanson mac je dois
faire je ne sais pas pourquoi un et dès
que j'ai entendu la maquette j'ai eu les
larmes magnifique dans les magnifiques
en plus elle parle de vous un petit peu
de moi aussi donc je remercie michel
berger france gall aussi un débit à ça
s'ajoute votre look parce que vous avez
des perruques blondes et gros chapeau
enfin vous avez une image en même temps
je savais qu'avec ma tête d'arabe
j'allais pas passer à la télé et je
savais que en brune ça n'est pas passé
voilà je sais pas pourquoi enfin voilà
les arabes ça passait pas l'époque il
n'est pas encore jamel debbouze est pas
encore voilà on n'était pas encore à la
mode a et donc je j'ai voulu à look qui
passe partout et sans savoir si j'étais
arabe black ou mais this way et comme
j'aime madonna j'aime marine monroe
j'aime marie doublage elles étaient
toutes blondes donc c'est le bloc et
c'est grâce aussi au blond je pense que
vous êtes fait remarquer voilà même s'il
fait remarquer par mellouk vous dire
vous êtes prêt à tout pour faire
remarquer le dit je suis consciente que
j'en faisais beaucoup beaucoup trop
c'est vrai mais en même temps ce qui a
fait aussi bien sur ma personnalité
alors de singles en album le succès va
continuer un jour fait un concert en
tunisie qui est la patrie d'origine de
votre père comme dix mille personnes qui
viennent nous voir à ma m quoi c'est
énorme puis s'il y avait un super beau
coucher de soleil c'est magnifique et
j'en garde un très bon souvenir bah
c'est super c'est touchant de revenir
sur la terre de ses parents les
l'olympia de fallois l'un perdrix alors
là c'est la célébrité quelles ont été
les réactions par exemple de votre mère
je sais qu'elle est contente ici elle
est contente ouais quand elle m'appelle
pour me demander de l'argent d'accord
et alors et vos soeurs et frères comment
ils sont très durs très très dur parce
que le problème c'est que quand on est
connu
le problème c'est c'est la famille parce
que au départ c'est bien ma soeur les
chanteuses à la chanteuse haouet est
assurée les chanteuses mal pourquoi tu
travailles dans une cantine pourquoi
t'es poissonnier pourquoi tu es là
et c'est pas facile pour les pour la
famille quoi ouais et vos copines de la
dass et de long bien vécu ce et ben en
fait j'en ai retrouvé 3
malheureusement deux de mes copines on
sont décédés un drogue alcool donc c'est
pas facile de sortir de la dass parce
qu'on peut soit vraiment s'en sortir on
soit tombé
voilà à l'époque quelles ont été vos
rapports avec les médias radio presse
télévision amnesty le tapis rouge avec
les médias c'était
60 ans que ça marche
tout le monde et on ne sape avec vous
mais ce qui me touche quand même même
quand ça va pas marcher les gens étaient
sympas avec moi un loyer de l'argent
j'en ai gagné au début oui
1,15 en effet j'ai mis de côté je me
suis acheté une maison
et
et que j'ai perdu que j'ai perdu mais
bon c'est pas grave la vie continue et
les questions amour alors vous avez fait
de la rencontrer le grand amour quand
oui oui j'ai rencontré le grand amour ça
fait 15 ans que je suis mariée on
s'entend très bien a bon il ya des hauts
des bas 1 quel a été le meilleur moment
de toute cette époque c'est quand je
chante ma première fois chanter pour
ceux qui sont loin de chez eux parce
qu'il faut comprendre chose c'est que
avant de passer à la télé
j'étais dans mon petit 15 mètres carrés
à métro voltaire
et là je regarde être machine et là je
me retrouve à chanter à être machine sur
m6 et je vois je pouvais même pas
chanter les paroles tout le monde
chantait la chanson et j'ai pleuré voilà
et le pire moment
aucun moment c'est quand ça marche plus
mais justement c'est à ce moment là que
luc plamondon vous propose le rôle
principal de sa nouvelle comédie
musicale cindy 2002 qui est une
relecture moderne de cendrillon vous
accepté sans hésiter vous auriez
peut-être pas dû parce que malgré une
promotion d'enfer cindy 2002 ne remplit
pas les salles qua non mais alors je
vous dire une chose cindy m'a beaucoup
sauvé parce que c'était à françois que
chantaient tous les soirs tous les soirs
tous les soirs pendant un an cours de
danse de théâtre de voilà c'était
nouveau pour moi donc pour moi je moi je
ne renie rien jeu
franchement ce qui m'a sauvé donc c'est
très bien c'est pourquoi ça n'a pas
marché à votre avis ils ont envie
peut-être trop grand dans une petite
salle ça aurait été mieux ouais mais
c'est au palais des congrès voilà les
critiques étaient pas terrible non plus
par exemple je suis allé voir rabbi
jacob j'avais bien j'avais adoré et les
critiques étaient mauvaises donc ça nous
laisse aussi
alors vous dites c'est à cette époque
que les portes se sont fermées j'ai du
mal à revenir
voilà c'est vrai que quand on sort d'un
échec on a du mal à revenir mais bon
c'est comme ça ta son j'ai peur de rien
c'est parce que l'avion heures
alors évidemment là c'est l'époque des
come back à répétition dans le disque et
il y aura le douloureux épisode du stade
de france vous chanter la marseillaise
vous chantez ça très bien c'est la seule
fois où mon père m'a dit que j'aime bien
chanter c'est quand j'ai chanté la
marseillaise et alors il ya eu des
sifflets quoi oui mais j'étais j'étais
préparé même si c'est dur on avait
prévenu là parce que moi le problème
c'est que j'ai un côté un peu en dedans
c'est que si on me siffle je peux être
vulgaire et je veux
et il m'a dit surtout tu fermes ta
gueule
en fait je suis fait quoi
je ne sais pas je pense aussi qu'il faut
aussi penser que les jeunes dans les
jeunes qui galèrent et
c'est pas juste pas c'était une façon
pour eux de s'exprimer et je pense aussi
que
il ya certes il ya une certaine personne
qui accepte pas qu une arabe chantent la
marseillaise grèce
c'est possible c'est une époque on
n'acceptait pas gainsbourg chanté la
marseillaise finalement alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes nostalgique de
l'époque de je veux chanter pour ceux
qui sont loin de chez eux a pas du tout
pas du tout un jeu pas du tout
nostalgique
je
j'aime aller de l'avant et j'ai envie de
passer à autre chose très très vite et
si c'était à refaire votre carrière
jusque là qu'est ce que vous ne referiez
pas pareil je raconterai - ma vie ouais
ne te raconter ma vie ça
ça crée pas mal de temps dans ma famille
et puis je trouve que
je suis pas quelqu'un comme mylène
farmer on sait rien et c'est bien c'est
bien de ne pas trop savoir parce que
quand on sait tout de vous c'est pas
bien le jour vous allez mourir cassoulet
qu'on marque sur votre tombe
celle qui a fait de son mieux ouais
c'est bien
c'est très heureux de rallumer la
lumière sur vos lames et bah c'est
gentil mais resservent il pour être sûr
de ne rien rater le leonard youtube
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu